all right is this on all right what up
guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to my
interview Series so
today
um I have a special guest on the channel
Rachel Wilson now for those of you that
don't know I actually interviewed Rachel
um last week the video hasn't come out
yet it's in the pipeline it's coming
um but I interviewed her about her book
um it's called occult feminism and it's
actually about the true history of
feminism but but today
um I'm actually not going to be talking
at all about feminism and the question I
had for Rachel so Rachel is um she's a
mother of five
and she was a stay-at-home mother and
she also homeschooled her children
and what I wanted to know is let's say
you're a woman that wants to start a
family and wants to go down that route
we constantly hear that we need two
incomes in order to support a family but
I've also done a little bit of research
and I've spoken to mothers and a lot of
them are telling me that no it's not as
expensive to raise kids as these people
are saying and this is just the
narrative that they push trying to get
mothers to work now I don't necessarily
know what's true and what's false so I
decided to bring Rachel on the channel
to give her take on
what number so if you're a woman right
we don't want the girls dating bums okay
we there's nobody in the manosphere I
know we have the anti-gold Digger stuff
you know but women we have to gold dig a
little bit let's just be honest like we
can't date men with no jobs all right so
um
I wanted to know
what income so if you're a girl and
you're 21 and you say I want to be a
mother and raise a family
how much money does he need to make and
where do you need to live and how how do
you structure your life in order to do
that like if I could if I could go back
in time and be 21 fresh out of school so
welcome welcome to the show Rachel I'm
pulling you up now thanks for having me
on
well this is
this is strongly feel like
women are propagandized constantly to
believe that all kinds of things about
motherhood that aren't true that it's
too expensive that you'll regret it if
you you know have all these kids and
don't have a career and that it's
dangerous and risky to have children
because you won't be financially secure
and it there's a ton of factors to
consider just because of the way things
are in the United States and probably
even in in Europe it depends where you
live how much things cost and things
like that but there's definitely ways
definitely ways to raise multiple kids
have a large family and if you want to
stay home with your kids to make that
work
um I have a whole bunch of data and
statistics for you but we should
probably just kind of start with how did
we get to the point where it's told to
everybody that we need two incomes to
survive right because it that's a new
thing it was never like that in all of
human history prior to about 1980 is
really when things changed and that's
because from 1960 to 1980 the workforce
almost doubled because of participation
in the labor force by women by married
women and mothers who previously rarely
were in the labor force so if we're
talking about the early 20th century
prior to suffrage it was a very tiny
amount of women who were married that
worked outside the home was only about
12 percent so once you got married it
was kind of expected you would stay home
and you'd probably be a mom and then
that number began to rise more and more
as the 20th century went on and as
women's Liberation propaganda got out
there and then World War II happened
and we had a lot of women go into the
workforce to cover for men who had gone
to the war but after the war most of
them went back home and that was what
the 40s yes that was the late 40s and um
the 60s is when things really started to
change because the Ford foundation and
the Rockefeller Foundation started to
create women's studies departments and
universities and they put massive
amounts of funding into women's suffrage
propaganda and women's Liberation
propaganda telling women that you know
it's very risky to be married and you
should have your own money and you
should have your own credit because what
if he leaves you or what if he becomes
an abuser suddenly that abuse mode just
flips on one day and he becomes like
this awful man and then you're trapped
right and you even saw a lot of that in
Pulp pop culture in the 70s with movies
like The Stepford Wives where and there
was a bunch of them there's a whole
series of movies that came out that made
it seem like enough wife and mom was
like boring and and unfulfilling that
being a career woman was exciting and
cool and that was what like the 60s is
that when the movies came out it was
like the late 60s and then through the
70s so in just a short period of time
about 20 years we saw just a huge
movement of women into the labor force
and it's hard to find comprehensive data
that proves one way or the other the
effect that had but the most
comprehensive study that's been done on
it was in 2002
um
and it was autor Lyle and asamoglu
that's a hard word to say sorry
um they did this massive study and they
used the exogenous variation in female
labor Supply before and after World War
II that's a very fancy way of saying how
did women jumping into the workforce and
then leaving again affect things and one
of the things they found was that for
every 10 increase in women's
participation in labor you saw men's
wages go down three to five percent
and another little piece that helps kind
of lend credibility and and backs this
up is that in 1930s Germany a lot of
women started entering the labor force
in factories and they actually had such
high rates of male unemployment and
depressed wages for men and even rises
in male suicide that the German
government had some laws put in that
married women it put restrictions on
married women working because they
wanted men to be able to have a living
wage and support a family because their
birth rate was going down and they
didn't want that
so
um there's a whole lot of reasons why
women believe this and there's some
truth to it because it we don't have a
family wage anymore we have an
individual wage now
so that's why in the 50s if you were a
janitor you could support like four kids
and a wife and your wife could stay home
that's pretty tough to do now although
there are ways to do it
um one thing is pay attention to where
you live I have uh data here from the
USDA which has tracked the cost of
raising a child since 1960 and they say
the most expensive places in the United
States to raise children is the urban
Northeast
and the most affordable places would be
in the rural and Suburban Midwest and
then the South so if you're outside of a
big city uh your housing costs go down
your daycare costs go down basically the
cost of living in general is lower and
you can probably get bigger a bigger
house for a lot less money in a place
like that so that would be like a very
big determining factor and also in those
places the wages for like men's jobs
industrial jobs
um trade jobs it's like kind of the
Bread Basket and the last remaining
sector where we have factories men can
get a pretty good wage in those places
compared to large cities where it might
be there might be more competition it
might be more difficult for men to get a
higher paying wage relative to the cost
of living
so my personal advice if you want to
stay home with your kids if you're young
and you're contemplating career versus
being a mom or like how do I balance
those
I think we give people we give women
backwards advice we tell them to go to
college get into a bunch of debt start a
career build a career and then after all
of that then you can think about getting
married and having kids well there's a
bunch of problems with that one is that
you're going to end up having your kids
much older one another problem is you've
got now that you've got this college
debt you want to pay it off so the
thought of quitting your jobs right
because because you've got student loan
debt to pay right right
so but this is what's happened and the
effects of that are that we've had a
huge drop in the birth rate since 1958
1960 when women started entering the
workforce the average woman had 3.58
children in 1958 by 2019 that number has
gone down to 1.3 wow
so 1.3 and you said it was three point
what
3.58 so over the last 50 years the
global fertility rate has been chopped
in half wow yeah that's a result of
women having kids much older the average
age that women would you know have a
baby 100 years does the average woman
have that's the other question that's a
lot too so isn't that like one out of
isn't it like one out of three women
have had an abortion yes wow and
um MSI is the UK version of Planned
Parenthood they average about 5 million
abortions a year
um in the United States I think it's
right it's been right around a million
1.21.3 million wow it'd be so
interesting to factor in like if they
had those children what the birth rate
would be it'd be so interesting it would
be higher
um yeah and the average age women are
having their first child now is 30. wow
and it used to be like 2021 years ago
so if you start when you're 30 you can't
have much of you having more than one or
two is just really unlikely that just
becomes really untenable so another
really important thing I think people
should know is that between 1950 and
2010 the rate of welfare spending in
both the UK and the United States has
gone up at the same exact rate as out of
wedlock births isn't that interesting
wow so the more out of wedlock bursts we
have our welfare spending goes up and if
you look at the two plotted out on a
graph they go up like this just in
perfect lock step with one another
so I mean we have a lot of good
statistics a lot of good data a lot of
good math that can't really be argued
with this shows that the more we
encourage women that they must focus on
Career the harder it becomes for them to
even look at motherhood as an option do
you know what I mean so if you wait till
your 30s your odds of having fertility
problems go up your odds of having a
child with complications or
um you know birth defects goes up so
that makes raising kids more expensive
as well
so my advice is if you think you want
kids
have your children young you can always
be going to college part-time while
you're raising your kids I have a friend
who did this she took like very
part-time classes it took her like 10
years but she got her Masters in early
childhood education with no debt at all
she was able to pay as she went because
she did it really slowly
and she was able to stay home with her
children do a little bit of daycare work
on the side and then now her youngest is
about to graduate and if she wants to
she can jump right into a good paying
job with a degree and she has no college
debt and she's still got to have her
three children and raise them at home
you know with her husband working so
there's ways to do it I understand that
it's not going to be like tenable for
every woman to just you know get married
at 19 and have their first baby at 20
and never work I understand we are where
we are and we have to work with what
we've got but there are definite ways to
mitigate the cost of having children and
I think homeschooling actually is one of
the ways to do that if you look at the
cost of child care and education that
accounts for 16 of the total cost of
raising a child from birth to age 17. so
if you homeschool them you're saving a
lot of money on public education costs
you know every year when you have to do
the best back to school shopping and you
get all the supplies and then you have
your your holiday parties throughout the
year at school you have school trips
there's like costs associated even with
Public Schools really because I always
say that public schools free
it's really not well and I mean who pays
for it the people who pay for public
school as Property Owners right it's
usually for by millage like property
taxes so
um it really incentivizes people in
large cities who are probably renters
but if you are one of the people paying
property tax I mean you're definitely
paying for school but there's also cost
associated with that especially nowadays
like when my my older kids were in
public school when they were little
before I figured everything out and uh
every year we'd get a list of like okay
you need to bring this much Kleenex
these many pencils pens uh hand
sanitizer they need to have spare
clothes to keep it school in case you
know they fall in a mud puddle or get
sick or something and then you would
have to do like this the Halloween party
the Christmas party The Valentines You
Gotta Buy Valentine for every kid in the
class and they go on multiple trips and
the trip costs twenty dollars plus you
gotta spend them send them with spending
money
um all the moms out there will know
exactly what I mean when it's like every
day or every week your kid comes up with
Something's Gonna cost you or they're
working on a science project you gotta
buy it and so that that's 16 so like
because okay I'm putting myself in in
in in in
that situation right but I'm thinking
like me I'm horrible at math like
horrible so how do you know I'm thinking
like I'm like oh God I could not teach
my children but I can't
so how does that work if you're not good
at a subject or maybe School wasn't
really your thing how does that work
so interestingly this is a a bunch of
data from Pew research and also from the
USDA showing that whether or not The
Homeschool parents had any teaching
certification or any experience teaching
the outcomes were roughly the same and
the wonderful thing nowadays is that we
have a ton of choices on curriculum on
my channel my next show is going to be
about homeschooling curriculum and how
to choose it and I have a really cool
publisher that I want to talk about who
makes homeschooling materials that are
from before the era of modern public
education they're like the classical
classical learning style those are
really easy to follow along with they
have teaching guides um so basically
like I always tell people I probably
learned more homeschooling my kids
really than I taught yeah wow so how
does that how does that like I'm just
trying to think a day in the life of you
homeschooling like the night before you
teach yourself whatever the lesson is
and then you teach it to your kids is
that how it works I don't know sorry if
this is a dumb question I just don't
know everyone
was styled but the way I do it is we
kind of just go along and then if I'm
like I don't know what this is I'm like
okay and then I'll show the kids if we
don't know this how do we find the
answer how do you look something up and
make sure that it's a good source that
you're getting the information from how
do you figure out something you don't
know where do you go to look for
information so you're kind of teaching
them how to teach themselves rather than
just spoon feeding them information and
we rarely spend more than like one to
two hours a day because you can be so
efficient and you can be so targeted in
what you're doing where when you think
about it and you're you're in a public
school for seven hours how much of the
seven hours are you learning nurses okay
I had cousins that were homeschooled
okay and I remember they would tell me
they would get out of like they're like
yeah we maybe do it until noon on a late
day and I was like
what and and I so my thought when I was
younger was that they were like they
couldn't have been learning as well
but you know now hindsight 2020 I'm like
were we the dumb ones like
it's about
other than actually teaching children
and I did a whole episode about the
history of the public school education
system and what it's about and it's
really there to teach kids to be like
obedient workers and military people it
came from the Prussian military model so
there's a whole backstory to why public
education is not very good at teaching
um but we do have really continuous data
for decades now that homeschooled kids
for 15 to 30 points higher across the
board on act and sat
um wow yeah and it doesn't seem to
matter if the parents are certified or
have any teaching experience and it also
doesn't seem to matter how much
regulation there is in your state
because the states are very different
like the state I live in does not have
much regulation other states have a lot
and it doesn't seem to matter they still
perform 15 to 30 percent higher on
standardized testing and there's a big
Trend with companies specifically
recruiting homeschool kids because they
tend to be self-starters good at
self-direction they tend to take
initiative and they tend to know how to
figure things out for themselves and the
schools are so controlled because my I
grew up with like entrepreneurs so my
mom always told me that school teaches
you nothing like which is a weird I
don't know why but and like even
um
I remember my mom wanted to take us to
Florida for like two weeks on vacation
and it was like hell because we had to
miss school and the way my mom thought
was and everything yeah no it wasn't
even the making it up because we're very
much like self-starters too you know
what I mean but um like my mom let us
miss school whenever we wanted which is
kind of a weird like but the way my mom
looked at it was as long as you can get
the work done like I don't care and that
this really would piss our school off
and so but the way my mom looked at it
was these are my kids I can do what I
want with them and and so but like the
school is like trying to tell us where
we have to be even if we pass our
classes like because I could have missed
two weeks of school and I would have
been fine because I I could teach myself
stuff too so it's
I I could just imagine the freedom you
would get with your kids by only having
to do work like two three hours a day
yeah and if you look at the average like
high schooler now a lot of them have to
get up at an ungodly hour like if you
live in a place where you have to ride
the bus to school maybe you have to get
on your bus at like seven seven thirty
in the morning so you've got to get up
at like 6 30 in the morning you go to
school for seven hours you probably have
like some kind of sports practice or
some kind of extra career yeah I would
go I would have five hours of training
at a three-hour volleyball and then a
two-hour basketball practice Yeah and
then you're supposed to do homework in
the average public school kid in high
school now has like an hour and a half
to two hours of homework per day which
is insane I'm like why are you there for
seven hours and you still have to come
home and do two more hours of school
yeah like midnight one in the morning
they get like six hours of sleep which
is terrible right growing kids and I
think that has something to do with how
we're seeing kids with Sleep Disorders
ADHD behavioral problems depression
because it's a total pressure and
they're not getting any sleep no that's
so true because that's how I was yeah
like ice to this day still have I would
say like horrible sleep patterns because
I never that's what I would miss so much
is because I just couldn't keep up I
would get home at like 10 11 at night
now I have this homework so my mom's
like yeah if you want to miss school go
ahead you know because you yeah what was
I supposed to do I don't know I I when
my older kids were in school I was just
like this is insane this is crazy to me
it seemed it just seemed so inefficient
and so backwards and so
um with my second oldest she's the first
one I started homeschooling and then now
the youngest two are completely
homeschooled and they have super high
reading scores
um and they learn so much more than just
like what you would learn in public
school like honestly they're public
school friends they'll be like Mom my
public school friends don't know this
and they don't know that and they have
no idea about this and
um because like I basically teach them
how to be an adult so I take them to the
bank with me if I go to the bank and I
explain how banking works and how the
banking system works I take them with me
to the grocery store and explain how we
budget our groceries and why we only
have this much to spend and how to
prioritize what we're gonna buy based on
that and
um how to figure out okay if this is 30
off right how do we calculate how much
this is going to cost if it's 30 off so
you're using like real world Hands-On
examples
and so they just picked stuff up so
quick and we just kind of have an
environment in our home that is just
really conducive to learning so they're
doing fantastic and honestly I if I had
one thing I could do back go back and do
over I would probably do more
homeschooling with the oldest she's
turned out fine but
um it's just so nice because they get
along great they're best friends they
help each other so one of them is really
good at math the other one's not
one of them is really good at writing
and the other one's not so they help
each other too so if they're doing math
one is helping the other if they're
doing their writing one's helping the
other how does it work are there like
tests that you guys have to take or like
I'm just wondering how testing would
work so me personally I do an assessment
like kind of like they do in public
school at the beginning and the end of
the year just to see where they're at
but by this point I kind of already know
you know what I mean so like I'll know
okay this one needs a little bit of work
on her math because she's struggling
there but she's like super far ahead in
her reading and writing so I don't like
push her and I don't have to push her
because she enjoys that so she she will
she's actually working on a book of her
own at 14 and she's been doing research
for it for a year and she's doing
absolutely fantastic so with that I'm
like okay I don't have to push that
she's gonna do it on her own because
she's already found something she loves
but she's a little weak in math so I'll
focus more on math with her so I can
really cater it to each child and what
they need so if I just give her like
maybe 45 minutes of working on math
every other day through the week it's
catching her up you can do it so fast
and people are under the impression that
oh man I'm gonna be sitting around the
kitchen table with them for like eight
hours and selling out papers and doing
tests and grading papers but I always
say there's no point to homeschooling if
it looks exactly like public school so
don't look at your public school
education and try to do that think about
your public school education and all the
things you wish you would have learned
like for me it was stuff like why didn't
they teach me how taxes work and how to
pay my taxes and like how that works why
didn't I learn some home economics and
personal finance and budgeting that
would have been way more helpful than
learning like Pythagorean theorem or
something like that right so I kind of
take the things I wish I knew more about
that I know now as an adult are really
useful and helpful and I focus on those
things and each family and each child is
going to have things that work for them
and it's okay to take your time to learn
that and figure it out as you go you
have plenty of time you'll get so much
done homeschooling in such a shorter
time than you think so
um I actually wrote a whole article
about this if you guys are interested I
can link that with all like details
about this stuff yeah wow that's so
interesting so you spent two I'm just
blown away two three hours a day on
school yeah
um what okay so because the common
complaints I hear about that is that the
kids won't be socialized
now okay I'm gonna give you kind of
Devil's Advocate both sides sure yes I
actually do agree to some extent so I'm
thinking of my cousins that were
homeschooled and they were a little bit
weird I won't lie to you but now in
hindsight I'm like you know what they're
weird with such a good thing in
hindsight because they like they were
outside all day they they like were so
involved in their Girl Scouts and boy
scouts when we were kids we're like
we're athletes what are they doing but
but I'm like in Hinds I'm like they know
so many skills
that are gonna have to be so useful and
I'm like my other cousin
I'm like yeah and it's weird because in
hindsight I'm like we are the weird ones
you know what I mean yeah yeah I mean
that's kind of how I feel but mine are
super social like if I take them out in
public I just took my 11 year old with
me to Nashville on a trip to see some
people and the adults were like how old
is she and I was like she's 11 and they
were like oh my gosh she sounds like
she's 18 and she's so she's very
precocious but she's super friendly
she's not shy neither of them are if I
take them out in public they're
perfectly well behaved they're really
really friendly they have good manners
they know how to talk to people they're
not nervous they're not shy but I mean
we go to church all the time and they're
in church youth group they've done
gymnastics they did softball uh tennis
yeah because they can still do most
States you can still do Public School
sports and extracurriculars and clubs
and things like that you can yeah if you
have a homeschool kid who wants to do
band you can sign them up just for the
ban practice and the reason is because
you're still paying the taxes to support
the school
oh that's amazing yeah so you can still
do a lot of that stuff in most places I
think there's a couple states that that
there's some restrictions so you have to
always check where you live what the
laws are but here and in most places
they can still do that
um and then yeah they've got there's
homeschool co-ops now which is so that's
a kind of a newer thing last five ten
years if you go to Facebook and search
for homeschool groups in your area
you'll probably find a bunch and so you
might have one parent who's a homeschool
teacher who was like a chemist and he'll
do like a chemistry project thing once a
week with the kids and they can go and
do that for a couple hours while you run
errands or something you can get to know
the parents and have like a sense of
community
and that's so useful to act cause I'm
just thinking
it would be so useful to talk to people
that are actually in the jobs because
you know the saying it's like those that
can't do teach yes exactly
wow and even the sports thing because
that was my thought like because I
really really liked Sports and I'm like
oh that would have been so sad if I
couldn't like be on a team or do any of
that stuff but you can still do that
stuff in Most states wow I had one
daughter who was really into
cheerleading and track and then the
other one was really into softball and
gymnastics and then the other two are
kind of like bookworms who are not super
interested in sports but one of them is
gonna start singing lessons because she
loves singing and so like there's a ton
of things you can do and especially now
with all of the internet stuff there's
like online tutors so if you have a kid
who's who wants to learn violin a lot of
times you can do virtual lessons if
you're not in an area where that's like
right next to you but there's a lot of
music teachers and all different kinds
of private tutoring and lessons you can
do if you can afford it but if you can't
there's so many resources online now
that I just feel like you'd be
hard-pressed to make the argument that
you can't find curriculum or you can't
figure it out right there's so many
options and um because you could even
I'm thinking for me I'm sorry I don't
mean to interrupt because I'm just like
I'm thinking you could even I mean you
don't even understand how bad I am at
math oh my gosh I'm so bad you don't
even understand it's like so sad and but
I'm thinking about like in my case you
could even if if a parent is really bad
at one thing you could find someone in
the community who's good like especially
if there's other homeschooled teachers
or parents you could always you know
because I'm really good at like writing
and reading and so I like I mean your
daughter you're talking about I relate
but I'm thinking you I'm sure you could
have other parents help out
yeah yeah I totally can and she's to the
point now where all her basic arithmetic
she's fine but the other good thing
about homeschooling is like with her I
knew pretty early on like okay she's
never gonna go into statistics she's not
going to be a mathematician and that's
fine and uh I didn't see any reason to
like push her super hard to be like no
you have to get to level two algebra or
or this is gonna work out like no I want
her I want her to be able to do all the
basic functions of life that kind of
math and aside from that there's no
point of pushing her in fact in like the
Japanese school system or like a lot of
the like Scandinavian countries they
start specializing kids a lot sooner
than we do in the states
um so like right around 13 14 years old
if you show like really great aptitude
for math they'll put you more into math
Fields so you can start preparing for a
career whereas in the United States we
have really broad generalization all the
way into like your second year of
college you know yeah I feel like
because as they're my kids and I know
them and I spend time with them all day
and I I'm homeschooling them I can see
where their strengths are and what they
like and I can see where their
weaknesses are in the stuff they're
probably you know there's just some
people they're never gonna be like a
great writer and that's fine
if they're great at science push them
into the Sciences a little earlier and
let them run with that if that's what
they want to do wow no that's so true
because I'm just I'm thinking I'm a
woman I'm solopolistic or whatever they
say
yeah yeah yeah so
so I'm thinking to myself I'm like there
would be no point in teaching me
accounting and teaching me because I'm
never gonna be good at that but I had a
really high aptitude for like stuff that
was more creative right and I'm like I
would have loved to have been in like a
specialized music class when I was a kid
but it's like how would I keep up with
that when I'm doing five hours of like
one I had to drive 30 minutes to to
school then I drove 45 minutes to Club
practice like it was such a crazy
schedule and on one hand I'm thankful
for it because I think it's made me a
pretty hard worker but but it's like you
could work so much smarter like it would
have been so much nicer as a kid to like
actually study what you're interested in
yeah yeah that's what they get to do and
we we do tons of Hands-On stuff kind of
like I said so if we're doing a baking
project okay we're gonna we're gonna
make banana bread when we're baking the
banana bread I can teach them about
chemistry by showing them why does the
baking soda work to make the bread
fluffy and like why does it rise because
then we can talk about pH the pH scale
and pH levels and we can learn fractions
by measuring like okay you need two and
a half cups of flour what's that oh
Netflix you know like grams versus
ounces and things like that so just
doing your normal everyday things you do
if you involve them and show them what
you're doing and explain it and then let
them try it it's just a super efficient
way of teaching I think it's worked
great for me that's so amazing okay so
that's 16 of of costs and on top of that
like they don't equate for your time
because either there's time your mom is
going to spend driving you to and from
everywhere like you know I'd imagine
that frees up so much of your day
it does and I feel like I really feel
like public school has become kind of
like a free daycare like they almost
pitch it to you as like a free daycare
somewhere to stick your kids for seven
hours so that Mom can work right
um and if you the number one highest
cost of raising children is daycare
costs
409 a week is the national average in
the U.S for a daycare for two kids wow
that's 20 grand a year
and the average woman makes 38.
yeah so average woman uh in the United
States makes 36
726 a little bit and I did a little
budget here just about the cost of moms
working so let's say you're making 36
000 a year you're the average woman I
know there's women that make more and
that's great fine for them but let's
just say you're an average mom and this
is about what you're making it's about
765 a week gross
if you're paying 409 for child care for
your two kids
um and then you have your work wardrobe
you probably buy lunch at least a couple
days a week but let's just say you're
packing your lunch and you're only
you're only buying lunch at work once a
week you are um driving a car that's
cash you don't have a second car loan
because a whole a second car loans a
whole nother 400. oh yeah that's true
but let's say you're being real smart
and you're being real Frugal about it
and you just buy a you know a five
thousand dollar Cash Car you're just
paying the average on insurance which is
like 200 bucks a month and then you have
your gas cost to commute back and forth
to work after you take all these costs
out the costs are 490 a week so you're
only bringing home
274 dollars a week and you're losing all
that time with your children all that
time with your kids and then you're
putting them in a state run institution
where now I mean I don't know if you
guys have seen public schools now but
the amount of bullying and violence the
amount of indoctrination with certain
ideas
uh a lot of higher rates of abuse
there's actually higher rates of abuse
in public schools than there are for
kids who live with both biological
parents at home
so yeah you're giving up all of that and
you're risking all of that and and
putting your kids in a really
inefficient Learning System so that you
can make 274 dollars a week on average
it's kind of nuts wow yeah and then
because that happened to my sister and
we went to Catholic school so it wasn't
even public and even them like they
showed my sister CNN kids and she came
out like my parents are both
conservative all right and thank God you
know it's funny I have a very liberal
personality you know you take a
personality test it can tell you if
you're liberal or conservative
luckily I spoke to my dad a lot about
these liberal ideas I would find
he was he would dispel all of them my
sister not so lucky she's come out Pro
drag shows
Pro how I'm like we have two
conservative parents they like in
doctorate it's like all these women that
didn't have kids so they're trying to
indoctrinate yours
well that's what I I
hateful on Twitter who don't love me
because I talk about these things and
they'll be like your kids are gonna be
weird I'm like okay even if my kids are
weird they're not going to get off the
school bus and come tell me that they're
switching genders
so
I mean I I had a girl tell me as far as
I can tell I interviewed a girl last
week who this the her she said her
school made her think she was gay
and she dated a girl for like two years
yeah
you see all those lives of tick tock
teachers you know who are putting all
the pride Flags in their classroom and
teaching their kindergartners about
being genderqueer and
I mean if you want if that's what you
want fine but I think there's tons of
parents out there who don't want that
and so that's why I do talk about this a
lot because I want them to know that
this is very doable it's very doable
even though we don't have a family wage
but to the extent that we can convince
mothers now if you're a single woman
you're not married yet and you want to
work or your kids are grown up and moved
out and you want to work again I don't
see any problem with that but if you're
a mom I think that you should try your
best to stay home and be home with your
kids as much as possible and if you want
to do that there's a lot of ways to do
that and if more and more women do wages
are going to go up for the men who are
trying to support families will see
something closer to a family wage than
what we have now
um there was like a
kind of a Middle Road proposal back in
the early 2000s when they were
discussing this problem where like
Charles Krauthammer was an old
conservative commentator and he said
maybe we should have a two-tiered system
where we have an individual
um minimum wage and then we have a
minimum wage for family wage so like if
you are the sole Breadwinner in the home
maybe there should be a different
minimum wage for that which caused all
kinds of controversy but it's a way to
think about how now everything is based
around this individual model rather than
a family model like it used to be so
so it does the more women the more
mothers that are working the harder it
is to have a family wage and I'd imagine
too if the moms working they have to eat
out more and they have to do more like
because
you can actually make food pretty cheap
I was shocked um I went I did a wife
School episode where we bought a week's
worth of groceries on I think it was 30
or 35 pounds and I didn't think you
could do it I was like there's no way
and you can yeah 35 pounds I was like
but no not not everybody can do this but
we live in a rural area this is what we
did because when we were young we didn't
have any money and by the time I got to
Baby number five my husband was like
okay it does no longer that's the other
thing if you want more than two kids
you're gonna have to make an insane
amount of money to have them all in
daycare or have a nanny for five kids so
for us that wasn't going to work either
so he's like well I'll do whatever I
have to do so you can stay home so he
worked a ton of hours for over a decade
and like ran himself into the ground so
that the kids could be home with me so
I'll be forever thankful to him for that
but we live in a rural area so we were
able to keep chickens and goats and have
a big old Garden which helped us a lot
with food costs and then the kids
learned how to grow their own food and
like raise chickens and have their eggs
and all that sort of stuff so if you've
got a garden with a bunch of potatoes
and you've got chickens and eggs
you've got food and it's cheap and you
can feed a big family on that kind of
thing so I know not everybody wants to
do that not everybody has to be a
homesteader but it's something you could
think about
how much does that cost like
it depends so like chickens are super
cheap chickens don't need a lot you can
give them like just a any kind of little
Coop like our first one was kind of like
cobbled together at home with like spare
Lumber just a little Coop where they can
go at night to roost and lay and then
they can wander in free range which is
actually better because then they're
eating all the bugs and worms and their
eggs have more more nutrition how did
you stop the freaking hours I would
always get eaten by raccoons
ours would go in at night and we didn't
have too too many Predator problems
there was one time that a dog got into
the coop and that was real bad but you
never really yeah you can do fencing if
you have like Predator problems and it's
for chickens it's cheap the bigger the
animals you get the more it's gonna cost
and that's not like doable for everybody
but I mean in World War II everybody had
Gardens and chickens and they called
them Victory Gardens because there was
food shortages and there was
um you know where they would put a limit
on how much you could have of certain
Goods so they would encourage the
American public to grow food and keep
chickens and call them Victory Gardens
so like even in Suburban areas people
did this back then so
yeah it's just something to think about
I realize not everybody wants to do that
nowadays but we loved it and it was fun
and the kids loved chasing chickens
around so
I'm really surprised you didn't have
Predator Pro that was like such a big we
grew up on 40 acres and I'm telling you
that it was there you would go out to
feed them and there would be a massacre
a massacre there would just be feathers
everywhere go oh
and that happens it does happen
sometimes but yeah there's things that
you can do to kind of like limit that
yeah yeah but okay so
one so one way you can offset food costs
is by growing your own food
or just sticking to I'm guessing like a
cheap budget in the store finding a
butcher I've heard where you get like
like Maple food
buying food in bulk
the really great thing too like we'll go
to Costco and get the giant bag of rice
a big huge thing of potatoes you get a
big bulk thing of like ground chuck or
something like that you know you get
your meat whatever it is and you we have
like the big chest freezer to store
stuff like that another great thing you
can do even if you're in the city go to
like a local farmer and buy a whole cow
or a half a cow you'll get way cheaper
meat and it's much better than grocery
store meat they don't put all the
fillers and dyes and all the weird stuff
in it so every year we would do like a
half a cow and a pig and put it all in
the freezer and then we always had food
and you just buy and sometimes we would
barter and trade so like my husband was
a gunsmith and he would trade
Gunsmithing work for like a pig or
something like that so I know it sounds
probably like old timey and um very
country to some people who are watching
but that's what we did and it worked
great if you could you do that even if
you have no skills in that like is that
something that can be easily learned and
like because like raising animals yeah
um well no that probably has a little
like raising cows has a little more of a
learning curve on it and you'd have to
have enough property to do that but we
didn't raise them ourselves we just had
neighbors that raised cows and pigs and
so we would barter and trade with them
or just buy a half a cow or a whole cow
because it's just a lot cheaper it would
be like you know two dollars and
something a pound instead of five or six
dollars a pound to do it that way to buy
things in bulk
um if you're just an average family
that's gonna have two kids this is much
easier if you're insane like me and you
love your babies and you have five or
six then it takes a little more
creativity and a little more willingness
to change your lifestyle like we didn't
do fancy family vacations we just had
one car for a long time and then when I
did get a second car we just bought it
cash
um and if you don't have a loan on it
the insurance is cheaper so we did we
cut a lot of costs you know we were
doing thrift shopping
um all that kind of stuff but as they
get older and you know the older
three-year adults now now there's more
money for things and stuff like that so
it's a it's a lot of sacrifice in some
areas on the front end of your life and
then you reap all the rewards of that
later in your life and you do get time
with your kids which you can't get back
you can't ever go back and get that back
for yourself so
so okay so you can offset
so what what are the other expenses that
go into raising children yes so the
other expenses are going to be
um so we talked about child care and
education we talked about yeah daycare
being the single biggest
um and then it's food which we kind of
talked about already clothing
um clothing it's like kids there's no
point of buying brand new clothes for
your kids when they're little if they're
high school age and they want something
cute or whatever even then we would
still go to like the higher end like
consignment stores where you can find
the name brand stuff but it's still a
little cheaper because they get sick of
it in two months at least mine there
were girls the older ones so they'd wear
like the really fashionable outfit for
two months be tired of it and take it
and swap it for other things
um and then when they're little I would
go to like
uh thrift stores and stuff and get them
closed because they're always tearing
holes in the knee anyway they're always
staining everything because they're
spilling on themselves and you know how
little kids are they're messy so there's
no point in buying brand new name brand
clothes for like little bitty kids they
had like nice Church outfit and then
they had all their play clothes which
were really cheap you can do garage
sales you can do swaps on Facebook so
like on Facebook Marketplace there's
often moms who are like getting rid of a
big batch of clothes that are the right
size for your kid and you can swap or
get them really cheap so clothing can be
really affordable for little kids what
would you recommend what did you spend
um a year on clothes for your kids
oh I was I'm I'm one of those like
really proud of getting stuff for cheap
kind of people so I would go to this
consignment store that's called Once
Upon a Child in the area that I live and
they would have twice a year will have
like a blowout sale where they give you
a big bag and you can fill the whole bag
with clothes for like 15 bucks wow yeah
and I could find them really good stuff
like sometimes I'd find them name brand
things that had like look like they'd
never been worn or might never have been
worn and fill up the whole bag I'd say
probably 200 bucks a year for five years
wow
and then I would brag to my husband I'd
be like yes I'm so good at this and you
know I say find the Dutch wife because
they don't like to spend money
wow okay so I'm just I'm just breaking
this down in my it doesn't like what
else do you need to spend on then
because now you've covered food you've
covered clothes you they're not going to
school
yeah so if you're my kids did have
access to electronics I didn't
completely like never let them have
Electronics what they were watching and
looking at was like tightly monitored so
they weren't getting into anything bad
for them but we didn't give them cell
phones until they were like 12.
um and I think a lot of parents think
that these three and four-year-old kids
need like a whole video game system and
a tablet and then they get them a phone
like they're getting them brand new
iPhones
um so the other costs I think that are
associated with kids are totally
like you can take it or leave it you
don't have to they're not necessary so
if you live somewhere where kids can
play out in the yard that's really cheap
get them a ball get them a ball in a
frisbee get them some bubbles you know
when they're little that kind of stuff
will totally entertain kids you can buy
used toys for really cheap
um other than that like those are the
main things even the usda's report on
raising a kid it says that the average
annual day care costs and then later the
college tuition are the most expensive
things and then after that it's food and
then clothing and then like medical
bills would be the other thing oh that's
cool right yeah that might be the thing
that you would have the hardest time
you know having control over because
it's going to depend on where you live
and what your income is and what Access
to Health Care you have
um so that might be the one that you
would have the hardest time manipulating
or getting the cost down because you
don't have as much control over it but
you can definitely make having a larger
family and staying home work if you're
willing to make some Lifestyle Changes
no you can't get the brand new Prada bag
every season and you probably can't take
too expensive vacations every year and
you probably can't lease a brand new
vehicle and you probably can't you know
live in a downtown Penthouse loft or
something but if you're willing to move
out of the city and you're willing to
make some lifestyle changes and some
sacrifices you can totally do it it just
depends on your priorities well and the
other thing I was I was thinking about I
feel like
I've always thought about I don't ever
want to get used to too nice of a
lifestyle
because it's going to have to go down
when you have kids there's no way so
like when the girls have like this cake
dot oh shoot this caked on makeup like
the false eyelashes fake I'm just like
how are you gonna afford that when you
have kids
you won't you yeah I you might have
noticed you could probably tell I'm not
getting lip fillers and Botox and lash
extensions and hair extensions and
liposuction and fake tanning and all of
these crazy expensive things but again
it's kind of a matter of priority and
honestly if you're if you're married and
you're being a good wife I don't think
that most of that stuff is necessary do
you know what I mean right
you're a good wife with a good attitude
who's doing her Duty and taking care of
this man's children and you're being a
good wife to him and when he comes home
from work you're appreciative I think
that's like probably the hardest thing
now for a lot of women is if they're
home all day with the kids and their
husband comes home the minute he hits
the door they probably want like a break
right oh I need a break
but my advice is give the guy a little
bit to decompress let him kick up his
feet and like check his phone and relax
for a little bit then if you need to go
do something or whatever he's probably
gonna be like oh yeah sure go ahead mine
always was but men need a little time
when they get in the door you can't just
like dump on them the minute they get in
the door so I think if you're if you're
being a good wife and you're doing your
best I don't think all the extra
I don't think men care about that as
much as we think they do I think that's
women competing with each other for like
clout you know what I mean they're
they're asking me about insurance
ask you about like they're saying ask
you about insurances
Health insurances car insurances are all
of it all
so we got like a bundle this is
something everybody probably knows about
but if you guys want me to tell you I
will so like through our insurance
provider we have our car insurance our
home insurance our life insurance and
then like protection on what's in our
house all under an umbrella like
insurance policy which makes it way
cheaper so if you go through one company
for all those things you can get massive
discounts health insurance is the
toughest and that's not something that
like I have a good solution for because
like I said we don't have control over
it so if you're lower income you
probably qualify for Medicaid wherever
you are in the United States I think if
the UK has something similar right for
low-income people there's like state
government Health Care it may not be the
best but it's something if your husband
has a good job he may get good insurance
through his work
um I never like the jobs that I worked I
never got good insurance anyway they're
my jobs now I'm sure there are women
that do and maybe that's like a
complicating factor that you got to
figure out but yeah I mean we just took
that into account my husband was like
when he would negotiate for a salary
with a company because he's in
mechanical engineering he would be like
look I this is what I need for benefits
can you do that or not and if they
couldn't it was like he would go
somewhere else but he had very high
demand skills
that he I mean and he learned them he
didn't go to college he was trained on
the job so he started with a company had
them pay for his training worked his way
up got more training worked his way up
till he got to a point where he was
making good money and had good benefits
and all of that and it took a few years
but that's how he did it so that he
didn't have to go into debt
um so if you have a working husband and
the mom wants to stay home have the
husband negotiate a good benefits
package as part of his job if that's
possible if you guys are really low
income and just starting out see if you
qualify for you know Medicaid or
something like that until you can get to
that point
I think that's like my best insurance
advice so what okay so what income does
a guy need to have in order to have a
wife that stays at home
so that that is the trade-off right is
like women we provide youth Beauty and
fertility and submissiveness in exchange
for resources because one thing you
learn when you have babies is that when
you're pregnant and when you are
postpartum and when you are nursing you
are no longer a strong independent woman
you need resources you can't like if you
got a baby attached to your boob for 16
out of every 24 hours
it's really tough to go to work can you
do it can you bring a pump and be in the
break room pumping milk and freezing it
so the nanny can feed the bit yes you
can I hated it I tried doing that when
my oldest kids were little and it was a
nightmare I remember sitting there
trying to pump milk and just crying
because I was exhausted it was horrible
um so you do want a man with resources
if this is what you want to do it
doesn't mean he has to make a ton but it
depends where you're going to be so if
you are like in the rural Midwest or the
South or in the suburbs where it's more
affordable you can probably have a good
family wage of like 45 50 000 a year
yeah as long as you are okay with maybe
having either just one car or you know
one car that you have that's your main
car and you have a payment and then the
other car is a cash car that's like a
spare for going around and getting
groceries or things like that it's not
your main car but it's like a backup
vehicle so if you're if you're cool with
make taking all those sacrifices and
lifestyle changes I was talking about 40
50k you can totally do it that's that's
about what we made for years when the
kids were all little that was my
question how many more than that now but
right how many kids could you do 40 50
we did it with five it was tight wow it
was tight but we did it and our
neighbors had 11 kids
and I want to say that their dad made
probably around 70 75. wow yeah they
were a Catholic Family and they kind of
did the same thing as us
um and yeah they had 11 so and that's in
the suburbs or yeah we're like rural
Midwest one of the cheapest areas
probably well do you mind what state are
you in Michigan oh you're in Michigan
okay yep
okay yeah so if if you're in corn
country
um and your husband can find either like
a good Factory job a good job in
agriculture that's the good thing about
being out here is that cost of living is
low but men's jobs like higher paying
men's jobs there's quite a few there's
quite a few around here
um if you're in urban areas it's going
to be stuff like Tech and you're going
to be in the city and everything's gonna
cost more
um there probably are ways to do it it's
but I don't know if you could do it with
five so you know what I mean like if
you're in New York City and you're
trying to find housing for a family of
seven that's going to be tough right
that's gonna be tough to do
um so what what are the what about okay
so what if you're in a big city what
does he have to make
that totally like I looked at some of
that data and it really depends because
the most expensive cities were
Washington DC New York La uh and Chicago
and the things that cost the most in
those areas are daycare and housing
those are like the two most expensive
factors so I mean you'd probably have to
make double that you'd probably have to
make like 80 grand I would guess oh 80.
but I would wonder could you like move
out because the Chicago
I'm from Chicago so I'm thinking like he
could commute like an hour and a half to
what it wouldn't be ideal but if you
wanted to go back on on
housing couldn't you do that like hour
hour and a half you totally could and
now another thing that has changed in a
big way since
um 2020
and the thing that happened in 2020 is
that they're estimating that 25 of all
jobs in North America will be remote
work by 2030.
so in just seven years a quarter of all
jobs are going to be remote work so that
does give people a lot of other options
so now something you could do is maybe
your husband works remotely and you guys
can live in a less expensive area or
maybe Mom can do part-time work from
home to help supplement while the
husband works outside of the home so
there's like multiple other ways you
could make it work because of remote
work now that we didn't have and it kind
of goes along with having all the
different homeschooling options because
of Technology too because we have other
ways to connect and find resources now
with the internet versus maybe 50 years
ago
wow you've convinced me on homeschooling
two three hours a day I'm like wow that
is amazing
yeah
um I have a whole series on my YouTube
channel about homeschooling for that
reason people ask me about that more
than they asked me about pretty much
anything so
I'm I'm always trying to convince people
because I mean the outcomes for kids are
so great and I feel like we don't have
connected families anymore children
spend like two hours a day with their
parents and it didn't used to like for
all of human history everything was very
interconnected you were spending time
with your family and your community and
your extended family right you'd see
your grandparents all the time your
aunts your uncles your cousins were
always around and everybody was always
doing things together and now everything
thing is atomized and everybody's
compartmentalized so Mom drops the kids
off to school and they probably go in
different buildings and the mom goes off
to her work and the dad goes off to his
work and then everybody's doing their
extracurriculars and their things that
they do and then everybody sees each
other for like an hour before bed if
they're lucky you know what I mean yeah
and I think that's another thing that
affects keeping families together
whereas if you have moms staying home
and homeschooling
it it promotes that bonding and
interconnectedness
in the family and then also within the
community so if you have multiple
homeschooling families working together
then you've got a support network and
that's something that moms are really
missing nowadays we used to have so much
support from like our our moms our
sisters our aunts our cousins and now it
feels very lonely it's like you're stuck
in the house by yourself while all of
your lady friends and your lady
relatives are often cubicles working and
you're you feel like you're the weirdo
who's staying home and you don't have
any support you don't have any help and
I think this is a way of creating
Community again because we've lost that
yeah and who's affecting and influencing
your kids too is the other thing
yeah the state the state and its
propaganda arm are going to be the
primary entity raising your kids so all
day long your children are going to
receive this different messaging they're
going to be getting whatever it is in
the school and it tends to be if you
guys know anything about like the
Department of Education it's extremely
liberal it's extremely Progressive and
they have a lot of you guys remember
maybe I'm older than a lot of people
watching but do you remember when they
would have like dare come to your school
or they have like yeah assemblies or
programs that are trying to give kids a
message well that stuff's getting
increasingly more and more left-wing and
more liberal Progressive it's very lgbtq
friendly and that sort of thing so even
the fact that they're talking to her
like sex ed that is
I swear I wish they would try to teach
my kids about sex out
that is the
that is the biggest I'm like if you're a
predator what what job are you gonna try
to do the one where you're talking to
the kids about set I might look at we
had no sex out of my high school and
there was not this crazy I don't really
know
one girl in four years that allegedly
got pregnant and she was crazy so I'm
not even sure if she was telling the
truth because she transferred you know
what I mean and so it's like they act
like they need to do like the parenting
for the parents yeah they do and so
that's part of the history of the public
education system was that it was it came
out of like Marxist ideas about the
state owning the children and not the
parents and wow really yeah the care of
the children should be about creating
good workers good industrial workers and
good like military service people for
the state
um that's that's where the model we have
now came from and sex ed has an even
creepier history because the curriculum
that we have in public schools now is
based on the work of Alfred Kinsey and
if you've never Googled Alfred Kinsey
and the children of I think it's the
children of table 31 for he did some
highly unethical experimentation on
infants and toddlers and children that
became the basis for what we teach kids
in sex ed now what if you if you were to
ever read it I don't even know what I
can say on YouTube because it's that bad
but what this man was doing studying he
studied sexuality in infants if that
gives you an idea
so he was doing things to infants to see
what happened if you stimulated them
I'll just put it that way this man was a
total lunatic creeper and it's his work
which was funded by the Rockefeller
Foundation that created the sex
education system in the United States so
me personally I just had a woman ask me
this yesterday because she said well my
daughter's about to do sex at in school
should I should I be in the class should
I let her do it and I said I would not I
taught my kids what I felt they needed
to know about that I do want them to
know how their body works and I want
them to understand biology but I was
able to teach it to them in a way that
didn't include how to insert things into
your anus or you know what happens when
two daddies have sex or things like that
because that's not the stuff that I want
a nine-year-old learning if that makes
sense so that's another big benefit
homeschooling is you have the control
over that and I know a lot of
progressives will be like oh you're
trying to teach you you're not teaching
kids what they need to know to be safe
and it's like you can do that and do
that in a way that's age-appropriate
create as those situated situations and
you know your kids too and that's the
thing like I have two sisters right I
mean well I have more than that but I'm
thinking of two of my sisters one sister
would have needed a sex talk a lot
earlier than my other sister because my
other sister like have you ever met an
18 year old that mentally is like 14 15
like you know she's just a naive like
kid the other one wasn't and so it's
like you know your kids and like when
they need that and they don't talk about
preserving the innocent I'm so glad like
my mom preserved my innocence as long as
she did you know what like they think
that kids need to know about all the
craziness that's going on in the world
why does a kid need to know that
like you shouldn't even really know what
sex is and in this idea that like if you
don't know what sex is that you're gonna
go out and do it it's like right no why
would you do it if you don't know what
it is like you wouldn't and part of the
agenda for why they want to push sex ed
earlier and earlier and teach crazier
and crazier things is because the
research does show that human sexuality
is very plastic it's very malleable so
if you insert these ideas into kids
brains when they're very young they find
it more acceptable
um and things like pornography
consumption the average child now first
finds porn on their phone or tablet at
around age 11. kids are being exposed to
this so young and if you start watching
that stuff at that age by the time you
get to 18 you have a completely warped
idea of what human sexuality is about
what's what a healthy sexual
relationship with another person looks
like you can develop addictions it's
just
this idea that exposing tiny kids to all
kinds of sexual stuff is good for them
like the data doesn't bear that out at
all yeah we know that that's not good
for them yeah and I remember being like
or like I mean not like 16 17. and there
was like something that you know sexual
that I didn't know what it was and this
girl like mentioned it at school and I
was like what's that and and everyone
was like making fun of me you know what
I but it wasn't like I had any
repercussions for not knowing what it
was like it was good why would you want
to inform kids about that stuff
um I mean yeah that's part of the idea
that like
oh your kids won't be cool or something
and I'm like that's fine because have
you ever noticed when we all get out of
high school it's the the big differences
that were there in high school kind of
Melt Away by the time you're like 25
everybody's kind of on an even playing
field again and the cool kids a lot of
them turn out to be losers and the nerdy
kids are the ones like running companies
and getting stuff done and being
successful so this idea that your kids
will be dorks who aren't sexually active
at 14. fine like I'm fine with that like
I'll take that over
um you know teaching them about you know
anal sex when they're five and they're
already you know it you are kind of
putting a stamp of validation on those
things because when when children when
their parents are teaching them
something the kid is going oh I must
need to know this because
it's gonna be something I'm doing right
so you're kind of
putting a little bit of a stamp of
approval on having like younger
unmarried sex when you're going now look
you're nine years old and you need to
know about all these different types of
sex and how all this works I taught my
younger my girls like things about
female stuff you know when they're
hitting puberty and they get their lady
time of the month I would teach them all
about that and explain what's going on
and how that works I'm not teaching them
about like
you know male ejaculation or whatever
when they're eight or nine years old
that's insane to me why would they need
to know that and if I'm telling it to
them they're thinking there's a reason
they need to know that so you can teach
them about stranger danger and all of
that kind of stuff without having to go
into graphic detail about things that
they're not ready for yet
what okay so can you break down the
budget of if you let's say you're 21 you
want to have five kids okay
um and
you've met met a guy that makes forty
thousand a year
in the country what how do you break
down the budget
so there's another thing to think about
when we're talking about the budget is
that the first kid is the most expensive
and then after my mom said that too yeah
yeah each subsequent kid is less
expensive because you're already kind of
set up for it so when you have your
first Baby You're Gonna Want a house
with at least two bedrooms probably so
that when the baby gets two or three
years old and they're out of their crib
and you want them in their own bed
they've got a bedroom and you and your
husband can have your privacy backs
let's say you find like a manufactured
home that's two bedrooms two baths out
in the country it's 150 000 right and
you maybe have a mortgage that's like
900 a month
and then
food for the three of you isn't going to
be too bad but the initial investment is
going to be stuff like you need a high
chair you need a car seat you need a
stroller
um you need a baby better crib for them
you're going to need to buy their first
outfits and all of those things now when
you get to Baby number two a couple of
years later that baby can now use the
oldest Ones high chair and car seat and
stroller and where where a lot of their
clothes some of the clothes are going to
get yucky you'll throw them out but a
lot of them can be reused by the other
kids because they grow out of them so
fast I remember my kids having outfits
that they wore once and grew out of it
you know what I mean so I had a lot of
clothes that I could still use for
subsequent kids
um let's say you've got your main car
that you have
um alone on that you have to pay every
month and that's your husband's commute
car and then you just buy a cash second
car maybe you're paying a total of I
think the average cost for a car
according to
um the data I have here is 1600 a year
for the commute back and forth to work
133 bucks a month if you do it cheap
if you want a nicer car it's going to
cost more but so you've got that and
then you've got your utilities you
probably need to make you know 4 000 a
month let's say okay so if if your
husband can bring home a thousand bucks
a week you'll be fine as long as you're
willing to be somewhat Frugal and you
know get your purse from Target instead
of from Balenciaga or whatever
um then you'll be fine and the second
baby is less expensive and the third
baby is even less expensive and I always
say three is the hardest and then after
that it actually gets easier
my mom said the same thing my mom said
she's like well I know who have a bunch
of kids they're always like yes three is
like the hardest it's like the sticking
point and then four five six or whatever
it gets a little bit easier because at
least for mine when the older ones were
like my oldest was 11 when my youngest
was born and at that point like when I
brought the littlest one home from the
hospital she was like I want to hold her
I want to feed her I want to like she
knew how to burp the baby like so I'd be
like I have to pee hold the baby and I
could like run and you know use the
bathroom or do something I had to do and
she I could reliably count on her to
like hold her for a minute it's not like
I'm dumping the entire care of the
infant on the lap of the 11 year old I'm
not saying that I'm just saying they
actually like to help and they want to
help or they can do more chores and
stuff I think that's another important
thing I always had my kids do chores
the and according to their age whatever
they could do that's what I had them do
so when they're like two or three years
old they can put away their toys they
can um you know put their dishes in the
sink when they're done eating things
like that when they get a little bit
older they can like wipe down the
kitchen table they can put out the
plates in the silverware when we're
gonna eat dinner and then as they get
older they can do more and you actually
want to teach them to do that and my
oldest one has told me multiple times
now she's like when I was little I
always thought it sucked because my
friends never really even had chores
they're because they had parents that
worked all the time and they were kind
of raised by their tablet and their TV
and didn't really have to do chores or
anything like that my daughter would
always be like why am I why am I out
here stacking firewood when I'm 13 or
whatever you know she's like why do I
have to do this but now she's like I am
so thankful that my parents taught me
how to take care of myself and how to
work because now I'm 22 and working
circles around everybody around me and
all my friends are really entitled and
don't know how to do anything so I think
having kids do their chores having them
pitch in and help is great so if you
want five yeah you're gonna have to make
more but the good thing is your your
husband's income will probably grow as
your family grows can you have kids like
my mom told me I don't know if this is
true or not that you can't have kids
like there has to be like when you're
breastfeeding you can't get pregnant is
that true
yeah usually when you're lactating you
don't ovulate that's not like a hundred
percent like so don't think of it as
birth control per se because you still
can get pregnant but it's it's much
harder it's like you usually won't
ovulate if you're lactating full time so
that's why
um my great grandmother probably had
30 periods through her whole life
because she had her first baby when she
was like 22 and she had four and she
nursed each one all the way till they
were like two so she'd nurse until they
were two and then probably sometime in
the next year she'd get pregnant again
so she'd be pregnant for nine months and
then she would nurse so it'd be like
three four years of no periods for her
with each kid if that makes sense so
um and there's a lot of health benefits
to that for women it's protective
against different cancers
um
and it's yeah it's like if you're
lactating and you're nursing all the
time you're probably not going to get
pregnant until the baby is starting to
wean so that's kind of a benefit less
hormonal birth control
I said that's why siblings are no less
than 10 months apart instead of nine how
long do you breastfeed for I don't even
know
um mine like 18 months to two years well
I think it's less yeah it gets less as
they get older so I nursed them full
time until
they were about one but by the time
they're one they're eating a lot of
solid food too so they would maybe only
nurse like right before a nap and right
before so when can you get pregnant
again if you have a kid like how old
would the first kid typically be
really like one and a half okay two
years somewhere it's a little different
for everybody but I was somebody that
all I had to do was sit next to my
husband and I would be pregnant
for me it was like pretty quick
um but it varies a little bit but yeah
like year and a half two years probably
before you have to worry too much about
it although everybody knows the story of
somebody who got pregnant like two
months after they had a baby it can
happen
okay interesting no because my mom said
that something people don't think about
is like you can't have kids back to back
to back you have to wait
yeah it usually if you're getting
pregnant again right away it's because
you're bottle feeding and there's some
people who do have to do that for
whatever reason you know anatomically or
other reasons there might be that
nursing didn't get established and maybe
they're bottle feeding then they can get
pregnant again right away
wow so 40 40 to 50 000 a year
wow I can't believe you can raise four
or five kids on that that is not the
message that is pushed that's not like a
stupid amount of money like that's
really attainable
yeah it is and I mean if you know a
little bit about the history of
population control propaganda you'll
know why this is the case started with
Thomas Malthus in like the 1700s and
then his ideas got reinvigorated at the
beginning of the 20th century by all the
women's lib activists they wanted women
in the workforce they did not want them
in the home and part of that was because
this is right after the first Industrial
Revolution where these giant Factory
owning like uh Gilded Age wealthy people
wanted a bigger labor pool with lower
wages and they figured out if you tell
women hey you can be independent and
have your own money and then you don't
have to depend on a man and like uh he
could be abusive and they would fear
Monger women to death about not being
able to trust men push them into the
workforce pay them crap
um and then it also lowers the men's
wages because now you've got this giant
labor pool right what's if you've got a
bunch of female Factory workers coming
in well they can on an assembly line
they can do a lot of the same things
women can do and so those men's wages
would get driven down and so it's great
for the wealthier upper class and then
on top of it you get to double your tax
base because now it's not just the
husband's wages being taxed it's the
woman's wages being taxed as well and
that's another thing you should think
about when you're deciding if Mom should
go to work because there's a not every
situation but a lot of situations you're
actually going to pay more in taxes if
the woman is working
what
all right so for
single women it's like what industries
do we go after for like husbands like
what what do you recommend dating for
like that make good husbands and work
well with a family
uh I say Tradesmen Tradesmen would be my
number one pick because they're they
never are unemployed I mean tech jobs
are great and some of them are really
high paying but we've seen times where
like Google or these big Tech
corporations have to lay off like a ton
of people or their job becomes obsolete
if you can find a Tradesman who can get
a good trade job I mean my husband no I
mean he would not only never be
unemployed but when he got good at
mechanical engineering
um which is and he's working on like
Factory equipment so like food
production companies uh factories he
would go in there and fix the giant
humongous Machinery that's in there that
has like robotic components and stuff
like that that's what he did and he
would not only never be out of a job but
he'd be at a good paying job and have
other companies trying to like recruit
him to their company and offer him more
so once he got a decent level of skill
there he could kind of negotiate what he
wanted he got to a point where he can
make really good money and negotiate a
really good package and
um he could do third shift if he felt
like that was better for the family so
he could be around a little more during
the day or maybe he'd want to do a first
shift job but there was like a lot of
options for hours for him to work too
um and then he would get overtime in the
overtime pay so if you're making like 35
bucks an hour and you're getting time
and a half for 10 hours that's a nice
paycheck you know what I mean so that's
so funny I've always wanted to marry an
engineer I swear I've always said that
yeah mechanical engineers like the guys
who are in there building stuff those
guys not only that but it's like they're
really handy around the house they tend
to be very mad I have always said that
but all my brothers are Engineers like
all of them yeah
yeah that's or even like um the them
auto mechanics or guys who work on farm
equipment
those guys tend to be really solid
because they're doer types
and they're gonna always have a job and
they're always going to make good money
um and they're probably going to be able
to get jobs in areas that are more
affordable versus if your husband is
like you know a lawyer or a tech guy you
you might have to live in Silicon Valley
or New York City or something and then
your options are more limited
um wow
well this has been so insightful like
this has actually been so helpful
because I think as women like we're just
always told that you need two incomes
and you're telling me and or you either
need two incomes or you need to find a
guy that makes two incomes but you're
saying that's not true you just need to
move to a suburb or uh the country find
a guy that makes forty to fifty thousand
a year and you can raise four to five
kids on that if he's in the city 70 to
80 but it's still you can still kind of
figure it out if you because I talked to
one woman who raised 10 kids on ten
thousand a year and her husband did work
in the city but they just lived two
hours from the city and she said it was
hard because she didn't like see him
much but it was just like a sacrifice
they made where she grew like she did
exactly what you did grew the food
um a little bit more so than you like
yeah I would guess that ten ten thousand
a year you would have to you'd have to
be like really homesteading but
um I think that that's I think that's
another thing we tell modern women that
is so detrimental to their chances of
staying married is that if you want a
good provider you cannot have this idea
in your head that every day he's got to
spend a lot of time with you and give
you tons of attention and you have to
have a date night every single week like
when we always think of it as like when
we call it like when we were in the
trenches so there's like five kids 11
and under and they're running around and
things are kind of chaotic and crazy and
there's a lot going on and it's just
busy all the time those years we if we
could watch a documentary and like eat
Chinese takeout together that was our
date but that was fine with me I just
wanted like if I got that little time
with him I was super happy and he made
it quality time if you want like a high
achieving guy who can provide a lot of
resources don't have the mindset that
you're gonna get like tons of attention
and tons of time and the higher status
man you get the less attention you're
gonna get and that's paradoxical for
most women right because the women who
want these Alpha High achiever type of
guys these high status men are usually
the type of women who need lots and lots
and lots of attention and validation and
so they're never happy
you gotta pick one a little bit if you
want or this successful man you'll
you'll get your time and attention with
him but you J it's not going to be tons
of it because they have demands on them
from their work from people around them
like my husband is the guy that
everybody comes to for advice about
things help with stuff because he's so
capable he's so good at everything he
does that he's all his time has a lot of
Demands so
now that the kids are older
and he doesn't have to put in an insane
amount of hours all the time we're
spending more time and this is another
thing to think about for moms that I
would say
if you want to stay home with your kids
you can do more once they get older so
now my youngest is 11 my oldest one is
22. I have more time that's why I can
stream with you I can write a book I Can
Do This research I can do some things on
the side because now I do have a little
bit of time but just understand that
there's different phases of your life
and if you want to have a career I would
tell you have your kids when you're
young that's when your fertility window
is and having babies is a young woman's
game it is hard to be getting up all
night with a crying baby when you're in
your late 30s let me tell you
um so have your kids young and then take
your time to think about what you want
to do and have some other things you can
do when you're older my last child will
move out when I'm 50. I might have
another 20 years that I can do whatever
that I could work or have a career if I
really wanted to for me I want to be a
very involved grandma and I want to be
helpful to my kids when they have their
kids so I'm probably not going to have a
full-time career but you do have that
option so I think we just give women
backwards advice telling them to build a
career and do college first and then
have kids after their first year I never
I never thought about not going to
college like I didn't even think it was
an option to be honest I know we tell
well we tell I had that beat into my
head too because I was a smart kid and
so it was always like of course you're
going to college it was it wasn't even
questioned it was like that's what
you're doing and I had my first daughter
when I was 20 and I was like I'm not
doing college and everyone around me
lost their minds it was like you're
never gonna be anything you're never
gonna go anywhere you're gonna right I
had people who were my friends say
things like oh it's such a shame you
never did anything with your life you
just had kids and I was like
excuse me like of course now it's not
like that and now that they're older and
they're going off into the world and
they're these solid happy
you know really functional not mentally
ill human beings that I've put out into
the world of course that's a wonderful
thing that's way more worth my time it's
a much better investment for me and for
society that I did that because I could
have worked some corporate job but
nobody would give a about it by the
time I retire you know what I mean yeah
and it's almost telling women that if
you don't have a career that you ain't
and you're a loser that's just such
a terrible thing to tell women
um they want to know about the cost of
giving birth
so I this is where I might get a get
into some trouble
um birth didn't used to be a medicalized
thing
for all of human history it was like you
had a midwife or your doctor would come
to your house and you most births were
home births uh you don't unless you have
a specific condition there are some
people like they have a high risk
pregnancy or something like that they
may need a hospital medical birth but
for the average healthy woman you should
strongly consider doing home births
there's a million resources on them out
there
um you can find women who have recorded
it like recorded their home birth and
have it out there on it on the internet
if you want to see what that's like but
you can get a midwife and do a home
birth for next to nothing
um if you don't need a medicalized birth
if you do need to give birth in a
hospital or that's what you want for
whatever reason
um you know see how much your insurance
covers and try to plan ahead for that
but
you can always do payment plans
hospitals are very good about payment
plans and if you got to pay a hundred
dollars a month Forever on it I mean
that might be something that you have to
do but I would really say look into home
birth because like I said 95 of women
don't need a medical birth and can
probably have a midwife and or a doctor
come to their home far cheaper you could
have a doula there's like a ton of
different options for that but we've
made it we've turned it into a medical
thing that cost twenty thousand dollars
to give birth and they try to make you
stay in the hospital for two or three
days after and that's not always
necessary either more often than not I'm
just so shocked by the 40 to 50. like
we've just been brainwashed to say that
we need two incomes and we don't
just don't realize how much of what they
think is true is fed to them through
propaganda it's so important especially
that's why I wrote the book The the
occult feminism book and I've got two
more books coming out this year because
people really just don't know they don't
know the history of how we got here and
why we believe these things when so like
compulsory public education is only 150
years old it's the new weird thing
homeschooling and other forms of
Education were the norm for all of
history medicalized Hospital births are
the new thing that only started in the
1950s prior to that 95 percent of people
born were born at home
um
women in the workforce is only 50 years
old prior to that the world somehow
functioned without women in the
workforce just fine
um and that's also the these are new
things the way that we're living right
now is new and it's a result of
um propaganda and different think tanks
and Foundations who create these
messages and then put them out into the
public sphere to convince people that
this is how it should be and that if
you're doing something else you're weird
you're in the out group you're you're
the bizarre person you're the weirdo
um but if you just kind of take a broad
look at history it's like no I mean we
didn't do things this way until really
recently wow and I was thinking like
because I grew up like traveling around
the world
um like we went I went to Japan when I
was like 12 we went to India we went
like we went all over and with
homeschooling you can actually like show
your kids the cultures you're learning
about in school
yeah as a family like that would be so
cool
we're gonna go um stay with my dad out
in Arizona for the winter because
Michigan Winters are brutal so we're
gonna probably go there for a couple of
months in the winter and it's fine
because everything I'm doing I can do
remotely there's school we can just do
it while we're out there so wherever you
are and whatever you're doing you can
still keep up on your school and fit it
in it's and you can spend more time with
your family the family in control you
know
Nest about it so if the kids are playing
a game with Dad and they're having like
the best time and they're laughing and
they're just like making memories and
enjoying themselves and it's like 10 p.m
I'm like I'll let them stay up a little
you know I'm gonna let them stay up and
spend time with their dad and enjoy
things and if we start homeschooling an
hour later tomorrow who cares nobody
cares it affects nothing
um whereas if they're in public school
you're a slave to whatever the public
school schedule is and you don't have a
choice about it
um and then you know if your kid I had a
child that got chronically ill and
missed like two months of school and it
was not her fault it was not our fault
and she was like heavily penalized by
the public school system and and they
were going to have her do a great over
and that's actually how I started
homeschooling because I was like oh no I
will catch her up myself if they're not
gonna help me and they're not gonna help
her I'll just do it myself and then I
was like wow this is way better than I
thought can I can I tell you a
homeschool story I think you would find
funny you're not a homeschooler public
or a my parents versus School
so yeah yeah we always had issues with
schools you know
um because again my parents are
entrepreneurs and when you have an
entrepreneur point of view
you just don't like rules do you know
what I mean like you don't like
structure like what works
right and my again my parents always
felt like I have like they knew me like
I was um a pretty tame kid right I
really didn't I think I drank the first
time I drank was like my senior year of
high school at the end of it you know I
wasn't in the parties if there were any
I wasn't invited shocking I know
um
for most of high school right you know
so still a teenager right but my mom
knew I was responsible enough to like
again go to school when I wanted to
and this might sound crazy to other
people right like you could ditch school
and not be crazy no I was just sleeping
like and I could catch up on it later
right like I was just okay I was never
an a student but I was good enough my
mom bees were okay C's were bad A's were
like you know my mom was just like A's
and B's good enough I could do that now
what happened was I went to Florida with
my family and this was one of my
favorite family vacations we went to
Florida for two weeks I didn't know that
you're not allowed to miss two weeks of
school just because your parents wants
you to I didn't know this and so I
didn't know my mom told them that I was
sick
oh so I came back and I'm in class and
I'm showing everyone pics from vacation
oh no do you know what I mean like I'm
sitting there like yeah this was so fun
now my English teacher already didn't
like me now she was so mad because she
was just one of those control freak like
we get crazy typical English teacher you
know and I I like English but let's just
call a spade a spade right now
so she's pissed right because I had been
missing her class all year because she
was my second period so I would always
miss I had to get in before third period
to practice so I would just always miss
first and second but I still had like a
B plus in her class I had like a and we
were in Catholic school so that's like
an 89 88. that's pretty good you know
what I mean like for never showing up
you know so this would enrage her this
would enrage her because I would just
show up halfway through it and whatever
and and you know but I would still do
good and and I'm so I made up everything
I missed and I did really well but she
went to the school and told them
to give me a zero for everything I
missed
because because she got the pictures off
of social media like this crazy lady why
does she care and yeah and long story
short my parents now here's the thing
I'll tell you one thing about being
growing up in a wealthy family
we can threaten to sue you
yeah
yeah and you actually have to be scared
because we've now are they looking to do
that
do they really want to do that Rachel no
but you're telling my mom what she can
and can't do with her child how is that
how does the state get to tell my mom
who pays extra money for Catholic School
they get to say you can't take your kid
on a family vacation to Florida even if
she has a B plus in the class which my
family deems as acceptable I know some
parents a plus only I just look at I was
in a b occasionally cease dude my mom
said that was good enough if my mom says
it's good enough why is it not good
enough and so
and so so yeah like in long story short
this woman who is not my mother pulls me
aside and tells me you are never going
to be successful in college well you are
never gonna be able to get away with
this you will fail at everything you do
in life like this woman gave me this
whole speech I graduated with two majors
no I went to college I graduated with
two majors three Varsity letters like
now you know I I succeeded in all the
things she said and so I'm just like why
is this crazy lady so bent out she had
her own kids I'm like don't worry about
it you know why I have a I know
something I know why she was like that
so the reason and it is an English
teacher thing because I had one that was
exactly the same way like that where it
was like oh you missed a few days in
class because the Prussian model of
Education was based on you remember
Pavlov and Pavlov's dog yeah the Bell
would ring the dogs would drool because
they learned to associate it with food
the pavlovian research of how to
condition people to follow rules is what
the Prussian model was based on and so
when they're training education when
they're training teachers and the
National Education board is training
them that's why everything is about
attendance and you know you have classes
that start at like 7 55 or 7
746 or some random weird number and then
you have a bell between every class you
have a lunch Bell and all these sort of
things and they base everything on
attendance and Rule following is because
the whole model is based on getting
everybody to conform and follow orders
and be good little obedient worker bees
and government drones it's wow here to
teach you to be a cog in the wheel they
don't teach you critical thinking
independent thinking they don't teach
you how to teach yourself or anything
like that because the model doesn't the
model doesn't reward that on purpose and
so your teacher was trained with this
mindset of this is what you have to do
and I heard that all the time growing up
too is like you need you need to go to
school to learn how to get up on time
and be somewhere on time and I was like
what well I have to go to school for 12
years so I can learn how to get up and
go somewhere on time and I was the same
as you I always missed I was Notorious
for missing first and second hour and I
had to make up I think I had to make up
34 hours of missed school my senior year
to graduate and I still got a 3.2
we deem that as good enough that my mom
that's what my mom said above a 3.0 good
enough
why do I need a 4.0 when I was
[Music]
I was successful with
so it's just it's also arbitrary and I
figured that out when I was pretty young
and then when my kids got into school
they were doing the same stuff to me
that they were doing with your parents
so I was just like okay how about you
just butt out and I'll just do it myself
then because it was yeah it was just it
felt so inefficient and so insane and I
didn't like the way anything was being
done so I was like I'll just do it
myself and
is the BET one of the best things we
ever did I think so and and it's so
people to go for it if you absolutely
hate it and you just you try for two
years and you absolutely can't make it
work the public school is still gonna be
there so just give it a shot that's what
I would say how do you know your kids
are like
um learning quick enough
because you
jump on things
huge vocabulary so that was one thing
just hearing how they talk you know what
I mean they're using like language at a
higher level than all of their peers
um and then as we're doing work or as
we're doing like an assessment at the
beginning or end of the year I can see
kind of where their weak spots are and
where they might need more and then when
they're like where they're like way
ahead so
I mean you're just you're with them all
day so you know them really well and
that's the other thing I like too
because when my teenagers were going
through stuff like teenagers do I feel
like if I had been at work all day I
wouldn't have noticed things right
because I was home and spending a lot of
time with them like I noticed when
something they didn't have to tell me
specifically but I'd be like what's
going on with you like something's off
and then they would be able to talk to
me about it so well and I started to
notice I'm like we kind of Outsource
families like even they have a therapist
in school now me I was a little God I I
hated school like I just I'm just a
creative I just don't think creatives do
well in the school environment but they
would they would have these therapists
there to tell like why does the school
need to know what your problems at home
are
what oh I have I had the school tell me
once when my oldest daughter was little
that when she is at the school she is
the property of the state
because they they did bring her into
like a counselor's office to at she
there was like a fight that went on or
something that she had seen and they
brought her into the counselor's office
and they were asking her things about
our house like that I was like that had
nothing to do with what happened why
were you doing that are you even allowed
to do that and they were like well when
your child is here Technically she's a
ward of the state and we can do what we
want well even even looking back like
the other issue you get with all these
people interacting with your kids is you
don't know what they're saying to them
and I don't know if you've ever had this
hindsight 2020 of like you get a little
older and you look back at some
conversations you had with adults and
you're thinking why did they speak to me
about that like there was one adult
um oh my gosh she was one of my nannies
because I did grow up I had nine
siblings and we were all in sports so we
did spend a lot of time around nannies
which I really actually don't recommend
you know I don't try to like put that
because my parents like they did the
best they could but I just wouldn't
recommend that to be honest because I
was thinking of this one Nanny that we
had
and I remember
telling her that I was um
she I was I liked princesses in like
some story or something and she was like
well maybe you like princesses more than
princes like how do you know you don't
like yeah and I was like if I was if she
kept pushing that like she did it it was
just like one conversation I remember
I'm like I might have thought cause I
was a tomboy so I'm like maybe I would
have thought I was gay or something if
they keep like because you're so
impressionable as a kid and I'm like you
don't know or I had another like a coach
that he said some like kind of weird and
it's just like in hindsight like you
don't know what these people are saying
to your kids and even my one of my
sisters like her it was like a horseback
riding coach was like this hippie lady
and you know she kind of put some like
feminist ideas in my sister and now she
my my sister who is probably the most
nurturing the most natural like a mother
like my like my one sister's just um she
didn't she was bad at sports so she just
spent more time at home than any of us
and she um like used to love babies and
now she's coming back I don't want to
have kids I'm like what
you but it's like yeah it's because the
like the all these outside forces like
are influencing your kids
yeah and I mean it all this is a system
the public education system is a system
the teachers are trained in University
the universities have people as
professors who are chosen and selected
because they're going to they're going
to follow the certain narrative right
that's how professors are chosen through
fellowships I have a piece on my sub
stack about
um institutional capture and how this
happens how do we get all of the
universities with these liberal Marxist
indoctrinators and it's because they're
hand chosen by the people where all the
funding comes from because they know
they're going to follow a certain
narrative so if you are um like a
feminist biased professor and they like
what your thesis was on or whatever they
give you grants they give you
fellowships they place you in a
university as a professor so all of the
feminist propaganda and other types of
propaganda all of the liberal marks of
stuff that's in universities it gets
taught to teachers and then teachers
teach it to their kids and almost every
public school teacher I've ever met is
this way and they think that it's their
job to teach people's kids about like
you know climate change or or social
justice or women's you know rights and
how how you should so if I were saying
to my daughter because I would say to my
daughters
if somebody asks you what you want to be
and your answer is a mom that is okay
not only is it okay it's cool because
when I was a kid that wasn't an
acceptable answer if somebody said what
do you want to be when you grow up
little girl it was like the 80s and 90s
and I was expected to say I want to be a
CEO or I want to be Beyonce or I want to
be Shira or a boss babe of some kind if
I said I want to be a mom they'd be like
that's not a job you have to choose a
career you know and I would tell my
girls if that's what you want to do that
is fine and don't let anybody tell you
that you're a loser if you don't have a
degree in a career and you want to raise
the Next Generation because that's super
important but Public School teachers
would probably hear my daughter say that
and try to counter what I'm saying and
give them a different messaging of well
but you want to be able to make sure you
can support yourself if your husband
leaves don't you and don't you want to
make sure that you have your own right
and what what if this and what if that
and they'll fear-monger them to death
about
how they must do things this way because
this is the agenda and this is the
narrative right so you have no control
over that when your kids are in public
school and we all know the
indoctrination we know about like the um
what's the curriculum they try to teach
them about
uh critical theory like critical race
Theory and that kind of stuff that
they're pushing in schools so
I just didn't want them basically being
brainwashed by the state is kind of how
I look at it yeah you've convinced me of
I'm like when I have kids I'm gonna
homeschool you you've officially
convinced me when you said two to three
hours a day like that gives you so much
more freedom yeah it gives you tons of
freedom and they and they also get to be
kids which I love they get to be outside
none of my kids are like overweight or
unhealthy because they're eating food
real food that I'm cooking them they're
playing outside all day they're getting
lots of sunshine lots of fresh air lots
of exercise they're not stuck and being
forced to just sit and then if they
can't just sit for seven hours a day and
pay attention they're being given pills
to try to make them pay attention
another weird thing they've introduced
that this came out of China
um it's like a Chinese model for for
basically mind control it's called
social emotional learning where they
they monitor everything about the kid
and they have like lots of new tech like
smart boards came out of this and now
they have technology that can read the
kids eye movements and all different
kinds of things so that if they're not
paying attention at certain parts of the
lesson or something it will tell the
teacher this and then it will send like
a report to the parents saying oh Johnny
Johnny paid attention pretty well for
the first half of the day but in the
second half of the day he's really
struggling and his mind is wandering
during English and like a whole other
control grid now so it's it's getting
worse it's not getting any better it's
if anything with technology and
surveillance it's getting worse where
they're just gonna start trying to
control the complete and total
development of your kids mind from like
infancy forward it's not well and oh
gosh it's gonna be like flashbacks to
how much I hated school God I hate
school like
no because I'm just someone
um I cannot learn unless I do it
yeah like I I yeah I have to do it and
so I would get so oh my gosh I I
remember like crying to my dad like I
remember like crying because my dad is
like really really smart and I remember
crying being like Dad especially because
I was a year young in school so everyone
in my grades was a year older than me
which okay it doesn't seem like that's
that big of a deal and you might relate
but like when you're younger it's like a
really big difference in just like
social maturity you catch up around like
seventh ish grade eighth but before that
it's like if you're 25 or like 10
percent younger than all your your
siblings or not your siblings or
classmates yeah um you just don't really
fit in so I remember like crying to my
dad and being like Oh I'm so stupid dad
and my dad just said yeah yeah my dad
just sat me down and he's like you're
gonna be smarter than all of these kids
because they're like and I promise you
like I was in a class with this many
people and I'm way more successful than
all of them because they don't know how
to think and I'm gonna like teach you
how to think and he's like and it
doesn't and he's like hard work is
always going to be smarts in the long
run like they might win in the short run
but you are always going to win in the
long run because you work hard hard and
he's like yeah and he and he was like
you can't teach that
right that is good job Pearl's Dad yeah
I love that because it's so true and the
kids who are successful at Public School
are successful because they are good at
following directions taking orders
warming a seat with their ass and
showing up on time that's what they're
good at they are not going to be taking
initiative they're not going to be um
Dynamic problem solvers in the workplace
they're not going to be the kind of
people who can work on their own without
Direction they're going to be followers
they're going to be little cogs little
Bots that are good at following
directions and you and you come out with
no like life skills to be honest like
and I'll say this like coming coming out
of it like there's a lot of stuff I've
had to learn in the last like couple of
years and like cooking is honestly one
of them which seems so simple but it's
like when would I have had time I I got
out of school at three I then waited an
hour to go to practice and then like
four to four to six I was playing
basketball and then I drove an hour to
volleyball and then it was like seven it
was like seven to ten at night I'm
playing volleyball and then I drive an
hour Home
what when do you learn how to do the
basic stuff
you don't you don't well I think so many
of us graduate from public school
feeling like that like okay I'm an adult
now and nobody told me nobody taught me
how to make a personal budget what do I
do with my money once I can save some
money like what are some smart
investment choices what are the
different things how much is it going to
cost for me to retire how do I pay my
taxes how do I know how to avoid paying
too much in tax like all of these adult
things that we get thrown into adult
life and have to figure out and every I
think everybody has moments where
they're like why did they spend like a
whole year on like Henry David Thoreau
in English class but didn't teach me
this stuff that I actually did I feel
almost all of us will graduate from high
school
and what I realized is like knowing how
to cook like 10 basic meals that you
know even from like scratch or whatever
your quality of life goes up so much
because it takes you a while to learn
them and get good at them but then once
you're good at them it's like you you
know it and then it's like what what
maybe took you two hours before is
taking you 20 minutes now and you can
like do it cook it eat it be done like
quick
yeah like my daughter when she was 12.
her friends thought she was lit and they
would always be like we want to be
homeschooled too because they thought
she was like a genius because she's like
well these bananas are starting to go
brown but I can make banana bread with
them and I can't eat it all at once but
I'll cut it in half and freeze half of
it so I have some for later and then she
was like be telling them about like
botany or like animal science or she'd
be telling them about neurology and
hormones and like crazy stuff that she's
learned in in homeschool because those
are the things that she found exciting
and interesting that she would go off
and kind of study on her own or like I
will give them a chance where they can
kind of work on what they want for part
of the week and she would always do
these reports on animals and she learned
so like a crazy amount of things about
Natural Sciences geography she's
learning about plants because she's
reading about what kind of plants
animals eat and why they avoid certain
plants that are toxic just all this
stuff she's learning and so when she's
just in normal conversations with her
friends talking about it they're just
like oh my God she's a genius or
something that's such a good idea
because my dad um that was like the one
advice my dad always told me he said
follow what you're interested in now you
know I was raised a little bit like a
tomboy you know because I've just
noticed it's like a daddy's girl thing
you know yeah
um for me yeah but my dad I didn't play
sports but I shoot guns and I actually
teach Firearms instruction with my Dad
yeah and I are both Firearms instructors
so we teach people how to shoot on the
weekends together so another part of
homeschool all my kids learn firearm
safety so there you go wow but no the
interest like my dad always told me
follow what you're interested in yeah
like that is always what my dad said he
said like don't do what like there was
no point like get really good at what
you're interested in don't spend a lot
of time learning what you're not
interested in because you're never gonna
be good at it so it's like the reason we
have the modern world is because of
specialization it's because of people
specializing in something and getting
super good at that thing and becoming an
expert at that so like I said I don't
feel like it makes any sense once
they're high school age to just like
hammer away at things is that they're
never going to care about and like force
them to do it number one it makes them
just hate learning it makes them just
dread school and they're like so I'm
like look you got to get your Basics
done but all of my kids had their Basics
done by like third or fourth grade they
could count they could add subtract
multiply divide they could read well
they could do some basic writing like
the Reading Writing arithmetic type of
stuff our great grandparents grew up
with they had all that pretty nailed
down by like third or fourth grade and
after that it was like okay clearly this
one loves writing and researching so I'm
gonna let her do that she's like me and
then this other one she doesn't give a
hoot about that but she likes math and
likes Tech stuff
um and then my son he would do like um
video game design there was a program we
found that would teach them how to write
code to create their own little video
games and things like that so he's
learning like basic programming and
stuff because he loves computers and
computer science so I would just totally
be like yeah just get your basic stuff
done and then after that you can take
like the next hour or whatever to work
on whatever you know he's working on
creating a video game this one's working
on her animal stuff and they could do
what they want and then sometimes they
would do things together and like work
together on something that is so amazing
this sounds like this sounds so amazing
I'm like you have sold me on homeschool
Yay good I was like I didn't think I was
smart enough to do it but I'm like I'm
like because I just hated everyone's
that's everyone's number one concern is
that they're not smart enough to do it
but if you think about it this way
who's going to teach your kid how to
hold their spoon and fork and feed
themselves who teaches them to tie their
shoe who potty trains them who teaches
them how to button a shirt properly or
how to buckle their seatbelt you're
already teaching your kids all kinds of
stuff from the minute that they're born
you know what I mean and even if they're
in public school you're teaching them
things so you can do it and there's a
ton of curriculum there like I said
there's homeschool cops there's so many
things to cover the gaps in what you're
good at or what you know that you're
gonna be fine you're going to be fine
I'm not a genius I promise
right but it kind of goes back to like
the work ethic thing because and that's
the one thing
I think that maybe I'm biased because I
have a strong work ethic but like I
think in wives like a lot of times we
talk about this femininity like it's
like these courses like soft
life I'm like our grandmothers did not
have a soft life
like what do you guys
argument about this on Twitter it was
like a three day long thing on Twitter
where I was saying exactly that I was
like femininity is not curling your hair
and wearing pretty dresses those are
great things I like feminine women I'm
all for that but I work really hard do
you think having five kids is like easy
like I'm just laying on the couch
watching soap operas all day heck no
like it was a lot of years of like not
much sleep and lots of work and feeling
pretty overwhelmed and the house is
messier than I would like it when
they're all small and like everybody
gets sick all at once and then you're
also sick and so you're cleaning other
people's barf and then you have to go
Bart like there's some really hard work
that goes into mothering and staying
home with kids it's not all easy for
sure but I think it's much more
worthwhile I would rather invest a ton
of time and Sweat Equity and and effort
into the lives of five people that think
about this if my five kids each have
three kids of their own I'll have 15
grandkids then the 15 grandkids each
have three kids of their own that's 45
kids so I'm having this huge ripple
effect on the future of society by what
I'm doing and it just changes the course
of everything a lot more than if I was
to just go be a secretary some somewhere
or like you know be a retail manager or
something like that so I felt like if
I'm gonna work hard I want it to be for
something that I care about and for
something that matters right not so that
some Corporation can like have a
slightly higher profit margin because
I'm there right so no I don't think
femininity is looking cute and sitting
with your feet up I think I come from a
long line of like Farm ladies and my
great grandma and my grandma they knew
how to garden they'd go back and like
butcher a chicken and pluck it and make
it for dinner and they could roll cigars
and they would sell cigars on the side
of the road to like help support their
family during the press the depression
and and this like they always worked
hard everybody it was all hands on deck
and everybody's working hard right so
well I don't like the princess mentality
yeah and they actually like it's always
the femininity course I just hate the
femininity like all the women that are
felt like I don't I can't tell you why I
think this or really articulated but
it's just like maybe you just know
when you hear it and so like
these women that are saying like soft
life you just need to be in your
feminine I'm like what does that even
mean like our great grandmothers had
super hard lives
super hard super hard I'm like this
wasn't like uh they worked in the home
but they still worked so this idea
you're just gonna sit on your ass while
your husband like maintains you I'm like
what the does that even mean
no that's that's a princessy fantasy
nonsense world that's for like point
five percent of women who will ever live
and I don't think it's realistic and I
think it's silly and I don't think it's
good for women either like I'm I'm very
much against the entitlement mentality
and the princess mentality
because this whole Twitter fight was
women were telling me that I'm basically
a feminist because I'm willing to pump
my own gas myself and I was like and
they had super super strong feelings
about
bumping the gas I was just like okay I'm
I'm raising I remember like nursing a
baby on one side holding a toddler on my
hip with the other side and then trying
to pick something up off the floor that
I dropped with like my foot you know and
I'm like doing four loads of laundry a
day several loads of dishes a day you're
running around doing errands you're
you're you're just so busy doing so much
but it's all like I said I don't mind
working hard just like you if it's for
something that I think truly matters so
that's that's why I chose the path that
I did but no this pampered princess
stuff
yeah it's just not for me and I don't
think it's realistic and why would you
want that you're not going to have
purpose or meaning
so wow well thank you so I enjoy our
conversation so much Rachel you're so
you were so um you were so smart I love
listening to you talk well you know
Pearl I've heard that you are evil that
you are an evil terrible awful person
and strangely you seem really nice to me
so yeah yeah you know I'm just a big
evil woman in my town it's so mean yeah
yeah I'll tell you why they all think
I'm evil because you know I just don't
like all right this is what irritates me
when we talk about men cheating all
right this this enrages the
conservatives I know they all were in my
DMs because they thought I was going to
be on here and they were like you better
take her to task on the cheating thing
but when I've heard so I've seen the
clips the out of context clips and I see
why they think that but then I've seen
the in context whole conversation where
you're saying like the whole situation
I'm like okay that makes way more sense
it's not this insane like yeah just let
men cheat it's fine like she didn't
actually say that
I have never said I've said no cheating
cheating bad bad bad
but but but if you're gonna get mad at
him for cheating let's talk about you
first
are you are like that's what I'm saying
like let's let's put it in the like you
know are you sleeping with him because
if you're not that could have let that
too I got in trouble for the same thing
I did a stream with a male friend of
mine where I said
for like us I think it's like a quarter
or a third of marriages end up being
sexless marriages
well I'm sorry but it is not fair for
you to say please marry me and sleep
with no one but me for the rest of my
life and then close down business you
can't do that that's spousal abuse in my
opinion unless that's abusive to tell a
man that you can't have sex with anyone
else but I'm not gonna have sex with you
either that's horrible yes and the other
thing is okay if we believe and I
believe this okay that sex and attention
is like like attention is to women is
Sexes to men we need attention from that
ideally fathers Brothers husband right
so so if you're gonna say oh he's evil
for cheating let's talk about you first
let's we can we can go into him but
let's let's let's get off of our high
horses women do you have a bunch of butt
pictures on Instagram
do you are you an attention seeking on
the internet have you ever responded to
a message from another guy because I
think that's equal
I think those are equally equally
cheating and I know maybe like the women
see it differently but my whole point is
like
why don't we what do they say take the
thing out of your own eye before
pointing at him and that's my whole
point is like were you being a good wife
did you contribute this to this in any
way if the answer is no I doubt it you
know what I mean like that's the thing
they act like they had nothing to do
with it and it can never be worked
through like okay he hooks up with a
stripper one time can we can we I think
bad bad
shrug it off like obviously you're gonna
be like very upset and devastated and
feel betrayed but I do I do agree with
you and this is everyone's gonna get mad
at me too I think if you're married and
you have children
you it's not automatic grounds for
divorce I know that's a horrible thing
everyone's gonna get mad but I do think
that you have to take the whole
situation into account and it's not
necessarily less traumatic for anyone
involved in that situation to just
immediately get a divorce kick the dad
out now everybody is heartbroken now
everybody is screwed you know what I
mean finally a based woman finally that
can list like it's like I mean my gram
my great grandma her husband
wasn't alcoholic he was quite a bad
alcoholic and he was not the nicest man
to be married to for certain periods of
their marriage and I think he did step
out on her once or twice
and she wasn't afraid to like let him
have it when he was really doing
something wrong or anything like that
but she stayed with him and she worked
it through and it was it turned out that
that was a period so they were married
they died when they were 99 and 102 and
they got married when they were 18 and
16. so what were they married like 80
years wow yeah and they had like 10 bad
years of the 80 years where he was
drinking too much and he was probably he
probably cheated on her once and twice
once or twice from what my grandma she
doesn't specifically say but she's like
says I kind of think he might have
stepped out on Mom once or twice and
she's like oh they had a rough time of
it for about 10 years but you know she
stuck by him and he he quit drinking he
got his act together and they kept the
family together and they had what 50
good years after that and that I think
that's more of the norm I think that's
the more normal thing if you spend 70
years with a person you don't think
you're going to have maybe 10 years that
are pretty crummy and for one reason for
another and it's like we used to we used
to try to keep it together and stick it
through and we didn't treat these things
as if they were the end of the world and
couldn't be worked through and it's like
even the women it's like okay so you've
never accepted attention from another
man ever
stay so the woman will get caught
cheating all the time and the man will
stay and the woman feels entitled like
he should stay the woman will always act
like well but he should stay because I
bring so much to the table and he should
you know it's it's just the attitude
that's so different I feel like women
feel like they deserve everything and
have no responsibility they get all of
the Liberation with none of the
responsibility and then the man is
supposed to have all the responsibility
but not get
any uh you know Grace or any forgiveness
for anything love you that was my point
like that right there is what I was
saying like can we we don't talk about
how we contributed and we offer no Grace
we offer no understand like guys are so
much hornier than us like they're so
like they're thinking about that
all the time like it's like you know and
I I don't agree cheating bad bad but
it's like we can't approving we're not
saying it's okay we're not saying that
you don't have a right to be upset if it
happens or anything like but he could he
could still be a good man and have made
a poor choice that that's my whole point
he could still be a good man but if you
treat him like he's the devil because he
made one mistake
or maybe even a couple mistakes it's
like okay if you're married 50 years and
he cheats on you three times are you
gonna focus on the three times or the 50
years
well I mean my husband and I went
through a phase where we we were just we
weren't married yet we were dating and
we split up for like six months but then
we got back together and we worked
everything through and it's like I know
there's people who would think that
while we were split up things that
happened would be like they'd be like oh
how could you forgive that but like I
said this is the normal thing it's
normal that
anytime you're in a marriage that's for
life and you have kids with someone
they're gone they're gonna disappoint
you they're going to things are not
going to go perfectly things are going
to go wrong and I feel like this is a
good way to explain the double standard
that we're trying to talk about so if a
man has an affair and abandons the
family he leaves and runs off with
another woman everyone will say he's a
piece of he's a deadbeat he's scum
he's a terrible person if a woman has an
affair and leaves the family for the guy
she's having an affair with most of the
people will say what they'll say well
what did he do to make her want to leave
what did he do wrong well you don't want
her to not be happy what was she
supposed to do stay in them would you be
unhappy and we never ask that when the
man leaves do you know what I mean like
maybe he did contribute if she left you
know I'm not I'm not saying he did it
it's possible but it's like maybe she
contributed if he left and that's it's
like we act like relationships don't go
both ways you know it's like when on
Twitter you asked for examples of female
evil and a certain prominent person in
the conservative sphere retweeted and
laughed all she had to say about it was
laugh emojis as though the idea that
females can be evil is just silly and
laughable and doesn't happen only men
are bad and only man men can ever be
evil like but that's the double standard
there is absolutely unequivocally 100 a
double standard and it doesn't make us
evil we're not being pick me girls we're
not being misogynists because we're just
pointing out like why is there this
double standard that when women cheat
it's very forgivable if they have
affairs if they leave the family
everyone's like well but what happened
to make her want to do that right and
they're concerned about her and don't
deem her but if it's the man it's just
demonization across the board nobody
questions it nobody asks like there's
women who are abusive to their husbands
there are women who are emotional like
this happened to my dad my dad was
married to a woman who did things to him
that if it was the other way around and
he was doing it to her it would have
absolutely been considered abuse and he
would have been thrown in jail but
because she was a woman everybody was
like well he should probably just be a
better husband then and I was like
excuse me that's my dad
I care about my dad he's a person you
know so I do see this and it does bother
me and every time I talk about it I get
people going but what about
but what about what about the woman what
about always their answer but what was
like okay we're talking about the men
now we could talk about the women later
but that's right that's where I was
coming from it's like what the
conservatives cannot hear me it's just
so crazy but they they're like well the
husband should stay faithful and I'm
like okay but and then the other thing
they don't talk about is like the
exchange of value like most men out earn
their wives so they're they're bringing
to the table like the provisioning more
so than not most men do out earn their
wives right just by and large so but the
women it's like we're not bringing the
Purity in the youth anymore like how can
you demonize him for cheating on you
when you literally are bringing a kid
from another man you know what I mean
like like he's the devil like he's the
like and I'm not saying he should you
know what I'm not saying he should but
I'm saying like hey we can maybe come in
with a little bit of understanding and
know that we're not perfect either right
right I know but if you even just say
that it's like people are not going to
hear all the other thing I had this
happen to me where I'm like why are you
not hearing the part where I'm saying
blah blah blah you're only hearing the
part where I'm saying the thing that
makes you mad and you're not listening
to the whole the whole conversation in
context and that is because people are
propagandized and brainwashed to think a
certain way every TV show every movie
that you've seen for the last 30 years
the husband is usually like some
bumbling who can't do anything for
himself he takes unnecessary risks and
is always getting himself into trouble
and the wife is like the sensible person
who always comes in to save the bumbling
silly man yeah Simpsons yes Simpsons
Everybody Loves Raymond uh Family Guy
and then every movie when there's like
an asteroid about to destroy the planet
Who's Gonna Save the Planet it's always
like a single mom female scientist
that's Gonna Save everybody and I'm like
what or it's some ass kicking chick
who's beating the hell out of Green
Berets like with her bare hands
so there's just I feel like there's a
lot of stuff that's out we're not saying
abuse is okay we're not saying cheating
is okay I've never said that and people
accuse me of that all the time no I'm
not saying spousal abuse is okay in
either direction I'm not saying
infidelity is okay in either direction
it's not
but we're very forgiving to women for
those things and we go well she couldn't
help and she wasn't happy and then if
men do it it's like he's a he's a
terrible bastard and he should just be
tossed out of society so well and I have
I have a friend um her mom just passed
away
um and they think it was because she was
Triple vaxed I'm not going to say but
she passed away you know heart attack at
60 with no prior conditions a weird
right but but but her
um her parents like went through a
period where he was cheating all the
time he was a Serial right and it was it
was really hard on their marriage but
they worked through it he I mean he
might have still did it but as far as
she knew he stopped
and when she died he she died with him
by her side and the last like 10 years
or 15 years of their marriage like they
were really really happy and so if she
had just thrown in the towel and said
he's a demon and a horrible person you
know she would have been alone in the
last 15 years of her life most likely
and is that a better outcome for her is
she more fulfilled even you telling that
story I bet that most women's knee-jerk
reaction to that story is like to think
that woman is a shitty woman or to think
that she's a loser doesn't care she
doesn't have any self-esteem for her
right like why would you if she's gonna
do but it's like that was her choice and
she obviously felt that that was worth
it and I don't think that we should
demonize those women either and think of
them as like weak or not having respect
for themselves it's
these are complicated things and people
and human beings and relationships are
complicated and marriages are not an
exception and people go into them
thinking that if things aren't perfect
you just
dissolve the marriage and that's not
realistic and half of women literally
have a backup husband so it's like
literally so it's like what yeah you
didn't know that it's like there's some
study you'd have to look it up but it's
like half of women have a backup husband
in mind in case like if something goes
wrong yeah and so but that's my point
and I'm like half of y'all have a work
like come on let's just call somebody to
spin I've heard half of you half of you
are getting attention from somewhere
else so if you're gonna demonize him for
getting set from getting sex from
somewhere else let's let's make sure
that your slate is clean and if it's not
clean maybe we can offer some
understanding is that crazy am I am I am
I totally off base you're an evil person
there's a study that came out of the UK
this big study they did showing that
divorce is actually a social contagion
so if you have a friend group and one of
the couples in the friend group gets
divorced the like likelihood of other
couples in that friend group getting
divorced in the same year goes up 80
percent over what it would have been so
it's another this is another thing
that's more female oriented so women
when their friend leaves her husband
that woman is far more likely to leave
her husband it's not as much for men so
if the man gets a divorce his buddies
aren't as likely to leave their wives
but with women if they're friend leaves
or their mom gets a divorce or their
sister gets a divorce the odds of her
doing the same thing goes way up and I
have the study somewhere I can send it
and people people this is a big big UK
study about that well and people used to
separate like my grandma my grandpa they
had like I don't know issues they
separated but they they still did
everything together it was still one
family unit and it was still completely
different than if you know he started a
new family with someone else and she's
like that that's a completely different
Dynamic like people used to separate
with the goal of getting back together
like okay maybe we can't get along right
now we're just gonna separate for a bit
and stay and and with the goal my
Grandpa died young so like they ended up
not but like even when they died like
when he died like she was still by his
bedside like she didn't have anyone you
know and that's the thing like it's
always let's throw in the towel instead
of try to work it out
and then and then they'll throw it in my
face they'll be like oh you're too
single or you're too young like you're
dead and I'm just like okay is what I'm
saying untrue is it untrue like is is it
better for a society for women to throw
in the towel at everything or is it
better for a society to stay together
like I don't think I need a degree
that's the point of the problem the
problem is that men are always
considered Expendable and they are
expected to sacrifice everything for the
good of society and their families women
are special protected class and they
should never have to sacrifice anything
women deserve to have it all really
should women should have a career and a
family and a husband who's never cheated
or looked at them cross-eyed and
everything needs to be nice for her and
she has to be happy and if the
children's I this is my biggest pet
peeve and I've said it a million times
if the children's childhoods must be
sacrificed and their dad has to get
kicked out and sorry kids you don't get
to see Daddy anymore because Mommy has
to be happy that's perfectly acceptable
to people and everybody will support
that and they won't bat an eye at it but
men are always Expendable and expected
to sacrifice for everyone else and the
good of society and it's just it is a
double standard and so I think all
family feminism has done is throw the
balance off and make it so that women
have all the advantages centered around
them I'm going to start asking should a
man date someone 20 should leave the
family for someone 20 years younger
because he's not happy looking at his
wife anymore
you know what people if you know how
yeah they say that you're single what
everyone says to me when they're like my
haters and my DMs will be like I can't
wait until your husband leaves you for
someone 20 years younger than you that's
like what they want to happen to me
because I'm willing to just talk about
these things honestly
um it's always I hope your husband
leaves you for a younger woman I'm like
that's a weird thing for a feminist to
say shouldn't you be against that but
that's what gets thrown at me so or they
they'll they're just they'll never be
happy I have a friend that's married and
pregnant they say she's faking it it's
just like
yeah yeah like she's got a belly like
what the
weird I know people people have started
rumors that me and my husband never got
married that were on the verge of
divorce that I have um like mixed race
kids from another relationship like the
rumors are wild just because like we're
a happy couple and he talks about this
stuff too he talks about the stuff
um on his show about and tells men that
you should get married and you should be
a dad and you should do your best to
help your wife stay home and raise your
kids and like he gets the same kind of
crap where they're so then they'll talk
about me or say awful things about
me to try to upset him so I they're
crazy
well thank you so much for coming on I
need to I'm gonna thank you so much for
having me on you got to be a regular on
here because I'm like I love our
conversations
yeah I do too it's and it's been very
interesting seeing you get so popular so
fast and talk about these things and I'm
like sometimes I feel like I get it bad
but I feel like you get it a lot worse
and I think people should listen to your
whole conversations in context before
they decide that you are the dark lord
or something yeah I'm just big evil a
lot of evilness here yeah just so mean
stay with your horrible husband
that's what they think I'm saying that's
that's what they hear you know yeah just
take the let them punch you in the face
and face and cheat on you just take it
yeah yeah yeah well thank you for coming
on
um absolutely uh our interview that I
did probably next week gonna be released
at some point so um she did come on last
week so guys
um make sure you like the video on your
way out I'm gonna I'm gonna take you off
the screen now so I'm just seeing you
okay okay thank you for coming
absolutely thanks thank you guys like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel ring the notification Bell
and let me know who you want me to bring
on next if there's anyone I should
interview
thank you for watching I'll talk to you
guys next time